now we're going on to a new topic which
is recurrent neural networks
so like
convolutional neural networks were used
for for modeling
images recurrent neural networks are
used for modeling
sequences data that arise as sequences
so here's some examples
so documents are sequences of words
and their relative positions have
meaning so the bag of words model we
didn't take the order of the words into
account
right it was just a bag of which words
were used no matter where they occurred
here we want to take the sequence of
words into account in the order
well time series such as weather data or
financial indices
those are sequences
recorded speech or music is a sequence
sequence of notes
or phonemes
handwriting such as a doctor's notes
is is a sequence okay
so rnns
that's the abbreviation for recurrent
neural networks they build models they
take into account the sequential nature
of the data
and in doing so they build a memory of
the past
just to get into notation so the feature
for each observation here is a sequence
of vectors
and the sequence is of length earlier
and so x1 x2 up to xl each of these are
vectors of numbers
so it's just like an input
feature vector but now we've got a
sequence of them
the target y is often of the usual kind
eg a single
variable such as sentiment for the whole
document
or perhaps a one hot vector for a
multi-class classification task
okay but it's just a single response
however y can also be a sequence such as
the same document in a different
language when you want to do language
translation
it's a more difficult case we're going
to deal with the simple case and and
work with the sentiment example first
so yes here's a simple recurrent neural
network architecture diagram
and
we showed first in this abbreviated form
and you can see there's like a cycle
going on which emphasizes the recurrent
nature
but then we represent it as a sequence
so here you've got your input sequence
x1 x2 x3 all the way till xl
and as you're going to see we're going
to treat each of our observations as
sequences of the same length
and if they're not
for whatever reasons the same length
we're going to force them to be the same
length in in the in what we do here
but there's versions that don't need
that
now along with the input sequence
you've got a hidden layer sequence
so these are activations just like we
had before but they march along in step
with the input sequence
so there's a1 a2 up to al
in this diagram each of these a's are
also a vector
x1 is a vector of input numbers
at this first point in the sequence a1
is going to be a vector maybe a
different size
of activation units at this first step
in the sequence
and they all feed into each other we'll
move along with the sequence
now you've got
weights so
let's look at the weight set for example
goes into a2
you get
you get input into a2 from x2
that's the corresponding
element of the input sequence
and you also get input into a2 from the
previous
hidden vector a1
so a2 gets input from a1 and and x2
a3 gets input from x3
and a2
and so what you can see is that these
a's are somehow
in a memory of what's happened in in the
sequence
the memory part is carried forward by
these a's
and you update the memory by
getting the memory from the previous
step
and augmenting
the information from the next input
vector in the sequence
and that gives you a3
the other thing here is that you'll
notice is that the same weights
are used at each of these steps as we
move along and that's where the name
recurrent comes from
the same weights
so a single set of weights w going from
the input vector to the
to the hidden unit and the same weight u
going from the previous
activation vector to the current
activation vector
we also shown an output
a set of output units
and again the same weights
go from the hidden unit to the output
unit
see these are known as bs
and that means we can actually measure
an output at each step along the
sequence but we typically interested in
the accumulated knowledge of the output
and so we're only interested in the last
one
which in this case is is y
but there are applications where
you
you could be interested in all of them
so yeah the parameters that need to be
learned are b u and w
so here's some more detail
suppose the elf element of the sequence
as p numbers p components right remember
each input
vector in the c is a vector in the
sequence
and let's say it's got p components
and let's suppose
each hidden
unit in that sequence of hidden units
has got k components
then the computation of the
kth components of the hidden units al is
given by this expression
so there's a bias or intercept
then there's a linear combination of the
p-values of the input vector at that
point l
and then a linear combination of the
activation units at the previous step
and then there's a non-linearity such as
relu
okay then the output layer
for example is just a linear model
right or if it's a classification it
will be a
soft max or logistic transform
as we said we we often only concerned
with the prediction o l at the end of
the sequence
right this guy
for example sentiment of the document so
i just want to ask go back to the
picture so if i guess we can see how
it's different than the bag of words we
did earlier in that because of the
ordering it's definitely taking into
account yes you're right and if we
didn't have those those u's that
moved from one unit to the next with it
would it be the same as a bag of words
it still wouldn't be the same rob but it
would it would certainly be a much more
complex network
but it wouldn't be the same
so there's a there's a quite a bit of
different structure going on here
and i should we should emphasize this is
a simple
recurrent neural network you can get
more complex ones for example
you can have two hidden layers so you
have instead of going straight to the
output layer you could have another
layer of of hidden units a sequence
right so this sequence would be input to
the next sequence
in a fairly obvious way
and there's lots of other ways you can
make this more general
so if you look at the loss that we're
trying to minimize
if we're only interested in the in this
response
from that the last layer this is what
we're going to look at we're going to
look at the observed response
minus the output from the last hidden
unit
right summed over observations from 1 to
n say if we're using squared error loss
and if we expand that out
you'll see all the weights that we need
to learn there's the betas which
comprise that b matrix of weights so
remember there were weights b
u and w these are typically matrices of
weights right that have to be learnt and
they're the same throughout here
so there's the b's there's the w's
there's the u's
but this loss only involves
the activation at point l minus one in
the sequence
so what about all the other guys
well the thing is
these a's are defined recursively
right
so
the a at la l minus one
depends on the a at layer l minus two
and so on it goes back
so when you when you come to estimate
the parameters you have to take all the
steps in the sequence into account we're
going to use an rnn on the imdb reviews
as opposed to the back of words model
so now the document
feature is a sequence of words let's
call mwl from 1 to l
and we typically
paired the documents to the same number
of words so here we're going to use the
first 500 words in the document if it's
longer than 500 words and if it's less
we'll just truncate and pad with blanks
up to 500. so now we need some way to
represent each word as a vector
well we're going to use a one hot
encoded binary vector dummy variable of
length 10 000.
and that may seem crazy that's a vector
of length 10 000
and all entries are zero except one
corresponding to the position of that
word in the dictionary so that's a very
sparse feature vector and we've got one
of those at each of the 500 steps in in
the document
so this is extremely sparse
what we tend to use
is a much lower dimensional pre-trained
word embedding matrix
and
i'm going to show you a picture of that
in the next slide
and what this does is reduces the binary
feature vector of length 10 000 to a
real feature vector of dimension
some number m much less than 10 k like
in the low hundreds
so here's the idea
so here's a sequence of words
at the bottom
you know this is one of the best forms
actually the best i've ever seen right
by the way what we've shown you is the
review
where we only represent the words in the
in the dictionary of size 10 000. so any
additional words have been deleted and
so you don't see them
and so yes this top imager represents a
one hot encoding right so this is in
gets a one in this position and the grey
our zeros
is gets a one in this position and so on
right
and of course it's ten thousand high not
whatever the number in this picture
here's the wording bed in and you can
see it's a much smaller set of numbers
and they're not just zeros and ones
they're real numbers so we've depicted
them as colors
right it's maybe a
a heat map of colors that goes from blue
which is cold to red which is hot with
with yellows and whatever and oranges in
between
and so now where do we get this word
embedding from
this this new representation so you can
see whenever we have a have instead of
having this coding we can use these
numbers instead
well these word embeddings are
pre-trained on very large corpora of
documents
and they use methods similar to
principal components
to come up with this lower dimensional
representation
and they're very clever they take into
account
things like synonyms so you have
you know if you have
you have a word like
male and female or boy and girl
the relative position between them in
this representation and king and queen
will be somewhat the same so they take
into account this kind of these kind of
um
you know semantic meanings of words
and also synonyms
so two of the well-known
embeddings are word to vec and glove
and
you can just these are available on the
on the web you can download them you
decide how many dimensions you want and
you just plug it into your network
okay
so we used an rnn with a word embedding
on the reviews data and after a lot of
work the results are disappointing 76
accuracy remember we got close to 89
percent accuracy
okay so then we fit a more exotic
recurrent neural network than the one
that we displayed
it's once known as the lstm which stands
for long and short-term memory
and without getting into great detail
yeah
al receives input both from a l minus 1
the previous hidden unit
that's the short-term memory as it well
is from a version that reaches further
back in time so you take big steps back
in time and and get an ale
back from there as well
right so that's the long-term memory
and when you do that it takes much
longer to train you now get 87 accuracy
which is slightly less than 88 percent
achieved by clement it takes a long time
to learn
now just like in the amnes data and in
the resnet and all these data bases
these data these imdb reviews have been
used as a benchmark for new rnn
architectures
so the best reported result found at the
time of writing was around 95
it's of course a much more complex
network
if you look in section 10.5.1 of the
book the second edition you'll see a
leader will point to a leaderboard
where you can see who's winning the race
and again subject to to overfit in and
and over over looking at the data
now this is something we've seen pretty
often right i mean
deep nets have some spectacular
successes but on a lot of problems
they don't do better or even they do
worse than simpler methods yes you don't
hear about that very much because it's
harder to publish simple things right
that's right
so just a reminder to
not only try deep nets and think fancy
methods but also try simpler methods
because they often work as well and
they're much simpler to understand